التشويق حاضنا في اخر ايام الميركاتو هالك
يخسر 7 كلغمات في مباراه واحده حدث انقلاب
حافله يهودي بحياه اربعه لاعبين هذه
الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
مانشستر سيتي الذي كان حجره اساسيه في
تشكيله جوارجيولا رحل في منتصف الموسم نحو
مريم يونس بعد المشاكل التي طفت الى السطح
مع مدربه الاسبانيه لكن هو قبل رحيله قام
اللاعب البرتغالي بحضر الجميع حسابات
مانشستر سيتي
قبل ان يزيل الحظر ربما لانه رحله على
سبيل الاعارات وقد يعود في الصيف المقبل
وبالحديث يعني انتقالات اللاعبين بلغت
الايثار ذروتهم في الميركاتو قبل ساعات من
اغلاق السوق الشتويه تصل الى بايرن وحكم
زي ش يقترب من التوقيع لي باريس سان
جيرمان
وصفقه انتقال جورجينا الى ارسنال بلغت
مراحل متقدمه بينما تابع مشجع جلسي فطائر
الخاصه لفريقهم وهي في طريقها الى
البرتغال لضم لاعب في كاس مقابل 100 وخمسه
ملايين يورو
اعتدهالك على الخروج بين الحين والاخر
بشيء لا يخلو من الغرب رغم ابتعاده عن
اللعب في اقوى الانديه النجم البرازيلي
وزن نفسه قبل مباراه فريقه اتلتيكو امام
97 كيلوغرام
في 90 دقيقه كانت كافيه له خساره سته كيلو
جرامات فعلا امر غريب وحتى ملامحه وهذا
توحي بانه مصدوم من جسم جسمه
في خبرنا الاخيره انقلبت حافله في
البرازيل كانت تقول له فريق الشباب لنادي
الرياضيه ماريا هيلنا ما ادري وفاته اربعه
لاعبين واصابه 29 شخصا بجروح الحافله
نحافظ على مصرها وسقطت من جسر على ارتفاع
10 امتار في ولايه ميناس جرايس جنوب الشرق
البلاد مستشفى ساو سلفادور كشف بان اللاعب
واحدا يبلغ من العمر 19 عاما بينما كان
البقيه تحت السن الثامن عشر